i told you that they're not going to  stop at abortion you don't stop after  you get your biggest win and we have now  heard from mitch mcconnell that maybe a  federal abortion ban is on the table  when mississippi governor tate reeves  was asked are you going after  contraception next he didn't say no  he said it's not a focus right now  and greg abbott from texas says they're  going to go after a supreme court ruling  that says the children of undocumented  immigrants have to be allowed to go to  public school he doesn't want that  they're going to try to overturn that  so they're not stopping at abortion  just like i said last week